ben en fait on s'est préparé c'était
vraiment fait signer l'ensemble à ce
qu'on était ce à dire une équipe qui a
besoin de se donner à fond de ne pas
réfléchir et surtout de soutenir tous à
coeur parce que franchement c'est une
saison on s'est battu il ya eu beaucoup
de difficultés beaucoup de
rebondissements mais voilà les objectifs
on les a obtenus old atteint et c'est
tout ce qu'ils écoutent la satisfaction
saison prochaine ce sera la prénationale
comment vous allez aborder ce
championnat qui est d'une division
supérieure on a déjà eu quelques joueurs
qui ont l'expérience de la prénationale
on va la présenter comme on appris dans
toutes les compétitions avec beaucoup de
travail beaucoup de vigueur c'est sûr
que là on va passer dans une autre élite
il faudra mettre plus d'applications
mais avec l'équipe on a le coach et le
staff conte avec nous on voit là on a
tout pour réussir il faut même si on va
pas viser tout de suite le championnat
mais on va faire des bonnes choses on va
se donner comme on a aussi donné ce soir